throughout the pandemic we've been
looking at what the data is telling us
where the lockdown is having an impact
and whether the numbers are starting to
peak let's have a look at where they are
at the moment this chart you might
remember it it's a very depressing short
indeed showing you the death toll in
various different countries around the
world the steeper these lines the faster
it's growing it's a logarithmic chart
showing you representations of growth
rates let's look at the UK in particular
and get a sense of whether since March
the 23rd there's been a change in this
line it's the crucial line that we're
all looking at and initially after
lockdown began still the growth rate was
that deaths were doubling every three
days and the implication was if that
growth rate had continued you'd be
seeing 40,000 people dead today of
Kovach 19 as opposed to what we now know
which has 12,000 868 deaths so clearly
the line has flat and in fact the week
after that it was doubling every four
days so you can see a slight flattening
and if that continued you would be
seeing 20,000 people dead today of kovin
19 rather than 12,000 868 in hospitals
of course so it's clear this line is
coming down and in the past week it has
been doubling every week an implication
from that is this that continued by the
end of this week it would still be below
20,000 so a lot better than the
extrapolations from previous weeks
suggesting the line has come down and if
you look at other data as well in
particular data on cases well you can
see here this is each of these bars is
how many new cases there have been each
day you can see the lockdown there as
well and it does look doesn't it as if
this has started to flatten as well
here's what the chief medical officer
says about that our view is that it's
probably reaching the peak overall and
that's what the flattening shows so
let's not everything is very important
we don't get to the point where we say
look are the numbers of deaths that
means we've passed the peak
so there is now some tentative optimism
about what the data is telling us about
Kovac 19 including this another data
series showing you people in hospital
with Kovac 19 and you can see their
London by far in a way that the biggest
of those lines but just look at that
that's coming down as well and so are
other regions as well so some hope some
glimmer of hope in the numbers at the
moment but everyone waiting for a few
more days data before we know for sure